uh try and make it a good one
so we have puya 2007
from iran 1900 and we're gonna get one
last five minute game before
the show is is over
we got ourselves another sicilian
let's see what line he's going to choose
this time
the night earth okay we'll go for one of
the
most critical lines here with um
i don't know actually what it's called
the bishop g5
maybe it doesn't even have a name
but anyway
um it's pretty illustrative the way
you're pushing forward with
bishop g5 f4 queen f3 long castle
that this is this is not a line where
you
mess around at all
this is a line where you go for
for the throat
actually i think e5
may have been
i have some sort of recollection that e5
may
be um a little bit premature there
um because you may take on d4 and then
ed d5 and then knight t5 maybe
i'm not too sure but after
after you take an e5 immediately i sort
of get everything that i want
yes it does get a um
half open d file that potentially can be
used for
an attack but his bishop on d5 is really
kind of dead at the moment and
i do get very quick play here with uh
with knight coming to e4 and um
also c4
and uh i i could have won a piece there
with uh
uh with um with a3 since the knight has
no retreating square but i was
trying to be trying to be acute with it
and in the process i missed a pretty
important detail which is that
after gf ef
6 he does have
queen c5 which ensures that he can
actually fight on
pretty well uh seeing as queen g3 can be
met by
queen g5 exchanging queens and there's
there's no mate um
so this means that um yeah you should
usually keep it simple
in these situations just go a3 and
win win the knight and on d5
and and in the process the game
now i could take on d7 but then he gets
to take on a2 at the release to bring
his knight back to b4 so
now i am going to to challenge his
knight
a couple of moves too late but what can
you do
he does like queen d5
and queen g6 king a1 knight c2
k2 i think i'm still doing well there
but at least it's very complicated
and sort of fitting for last last game
of the day
now however saving the bishop was not
the correct idea since that bishop is
um the bishop is really really poor
being hammed in by his own pawns he does
find the only way to
save his queen though here to to his
credit
i don't think i can actually trap the
queen like queen f4
there's e5 um
if yeah if queen h5 that would have been
g4 so that's a trap but
e5 and then don't have a good square for
the queen
queen and he can go queen g4 later on
so i don't think i'm trapping trapping
the queens i'll just
grab the free bishop
um
okay uh anyway i'm bringing the rook
into the game
yeah i guess i must miss rick d5 there
with a one on the spot
what can i say you can't see everything
not even close f4 now there's queen e4
uh so he has to go over to
rook to eight but obviously i'm winning
winning a
in a number of ways i think root g6 it's
not the only move but it's
quite instructive in the way that i'm
just removing my
my pawns so that um
his king has no no protection whatsoever
now rook h1 and he's in huge trouble
the normal way to protect the
pawn on on h6 would have been king g7
then i had rook g1
winning the queen now after h5
rook g7 is forced because queen g7 rook
h5 is made for king h7
bishop f5 wins the queen but here
obviously is still
in a world of trouble for instance queen
g5 queen e8
followed by queen h5 sorry rook h5 wins
the queen
and um
[Music]
and that's going to be the end of the
game